in this talk I'm going to talk about
some recent instructional amounts for
that to stretchable circuits the
hopefully I've altered about some
potential approach to pool lower bound
for that to stretch all circuits so okay
first some definitions Ryan already
covered them so I just go through them
quickly so stretch locate is just a
function of an indicator of the
intersection of a bouillon cube and half
half space so it's just weather tableau
dot X is bigger than T so that W here
will be a that will he ever be a will be
a vector and achieve an integer and put
majority case which is a it's a special
case where they are post under the
paranormal so stretchy love stretcher is
just a tough stretch of function
composed with the menu structure
function at the panel area and the
similarly you can define stretches of
majority majority of stretch hole and
the majority of majorities so some
histories especially bound and known for
all these special classes for majority
of majority from a judge of stretch hold
and for stretch of majority actually
this to crack a fat equivalent but for
stretch of stretch hold last week we
know that we we know very little so we
don't even know whether enact the
non-deterministic exponential time is
contained in the stretch of stretch out
another time so it needs talk when
there's no no see before the car crash I
was sat down for another size mm-hm
so in this talk I'm going to talk about
some potential approaches for resolving
this open question
Ryan Williams has a rhythmic approach to
a lower bounce so basically say
something like a lower bounce for cuts
for foresee will arrive by designing
some non-trivial algorithms for C that's
actually some strategy here because you
know you usually weigh up think about
this there will be some depth increase
the we are thinking about six step
circuit like stretch of a stretch hold
it turns out we can make use of some
structure of structural kids to get rid
of the taps increase yeah so a natural
question is how hot is the algorithmic
analysis abstraction of structural
circuits so for example how tired
compared to stretch of majority or
majority majority circuits in this work
I will show actually from the
perspective of for designing algorithm
for them we are equally hard or using
this is quite an intuitive because we
know that exponential separation between
them as some as the conditional model
themself so what's the original question
we are interesting in the first line is
the most basic question we are we all of
the streets a question so we are given a
circuit and we are we have whether
there's an input which makes this
circuit satisfiable
and the second question is take a pee
pee pee pee cap so it's basically just
that your animation question to react
you a circuit and one who estimate the
acceptability while my wife given our
rendering input with some native arrow
absol so now we define what is
non-trivial algorithms for non-trivial
said well we want to shape a super
polynomial factor from the from the
trivial to the input force algorithm and
for the non-trivial cap want to
associate these two pranaam be a factor
but we also want the arrow to be
something like code for every universe
trinomial function and this is it is
useful for some later technical
deterioration that we also you know with
a slide so talk about a first result
so first way now is pronoun now site
structure of stretch out and a stretch
of majority an equivalent for
non-trivial set of reasons
so what I will make with me so you we
have a away the can save our super per
number factor for stretch of majority
that algorithm then we can estimate with
the for stretch up stretch hole the
second without is phenomenal size
stretches of stretch hold and the
majority majority an equivalent for
non-trivial cap algorithms so we can
given a nice majority of majority which
seems but we seems nice simpler because
we know it's not a lower bound even
strategy just save a superb another
factor and this will get us some
generous some non-trivial
category the for stretch of stretch hold
and it will can ask the rope on one
first I don't talk about why we need the
new structure lemma as in the public so
anyway we want to like connect the
stretch of stretch of animated medicham
pejorative
to make use of the every the for for
this class so we know that's a very all
the without actually older than me
so it shows something like set up
special it's the vast majority of
majority of majority circuits but the
question here is like we only have major
majority and the test actually is is
increased and we don't know how to make
yourself that that's to case for sub -
three kids so we don't we cannot we
cannot rely under this old structure
remark here mmm but what if we had a top
or gate so imagine this gate is now oh
so the people will be happy so because
so what we have an algorithm for
straight set then automatically impact
our weather for of safe set right
because you can't just enumerate all
these sub circuits and apply the
algorithm for each of them and since we
have a non-trivial saving up to the
polynomial a pranaam you're Fanning here
it's okay and also what we have at is
join our pocket it is journalized just
something it's a promise orchid which
most wine input is a virtue they said
this is actually even better look at he
very happy so because because the
because you know come back with kebab we
want to estimate the probability of
acceptable I ran an input but he's
turning a wise data some so you can't
just sum them up just try each sub
circuits and some the poverty art and
this is why we wanted the epsilon to be
one over a polynomial over a polynomial
because then the the fan here will make
you do some arrow
I'm going to talk about you me give me
how to read this so what for cattle we
have to use joint over got it has done
now the filling of the door can be
almost exponential right yeah I think
depends on depends on the algorithm I
think because then with determination
here non-trivial means only save up
super polynomial factor yeah yes I think
it has some connection with other every
that you wait relax the definitions here
yes actually and I will talk about this
later
yeah okay so this is our first actual
Emma so a special of special gate
circuit can be explicitly written which
means that that I will then can
construct this this the on position and
then or anomaly many stretches of
majorities the kids
so that revealed color it will have we
have you handshape super normal factor
from the said agua the for strata of
majority as well automatically in PI a
similar algorithm for threshold of
stretch whole this is good okay
structure and that - it's more
complicated so after with rhythm
carefully so for parameter epsilon we
shall very special special circuit of
set s with any input can be explicitly
written as at disjoint or of majority of
majority circuits such that the top gate
has a true to the external fanging
and the on majority majority of circuits
have sides as to one over a stone so
here are two concrete settings so when
we said a stone to be actually small
constant then can write stretch of
strata as a stub expansion is joint OA
of a majority majority and you with an
epsilon to be much smaller that we can
write such a special as a pre-nominal
disjoint OA of sub-exponential size
which is majority of majority and this
can also be applied to to the point
where the pattern function is that is
that n so we're going to show something
like for absol every stretch of end
function of this side of an impose can
be written as that disjoint or after
maturity of end circuit so this is
actually just a polynomial function of
degree K and the parameter are similar
so so the color is PDF of degree K with
actually width can be written as that
sub-exponential disjoint OA of freedom
of a PDF with pronoun no wait by the way
the degree to kick
yeah we have some constraint on the on
the on the on the banging but yeah it's
okay we don't have constraint yeah yeah
yeah so the first open question I want
to ask is can we strengthen this lemma
from stress a lot of majority to
majority majority so can we show stretch
up stretch of the can we read write a
straight up special exam
well not only many majority majority
this world showed that equipment for
non-trivial algorithms I only show
something that's interesting and so a
non-trivial shop set up with for magenta
majority were in PI and uncivil
non-deterministic I'm stuck with the for
set up special it seems very available
this is already enough for relaxed is
not in structured schedule so I Austin
this is set to this chapter to just that
that'll be interesting so this is I'm
going to talk about why we can't get rid
of the tax increase issues because in
the past optimize the version of the
lower bound by algorithm implement we
actually need a set algorithm for entry
of see not just see
but well to get an implication for
stretch of special themself so we cannot
really have this pathway an increase in
the depth which is cut out some problem
and actually we don't know whether
industry of stretch up stretch out you
know stretch up stretch out actually
maybe not so where to deal with them so
where we eat some have fun at you - -
whole case which is a close relative of
stretch okay so now the definition is
that we changed the eye socket is that
is an indicator function of tableau talk
x equals T for not smaller than T that
some structural results for connecting
this to with these two types of gates so
the first one is a structure located can
be written as a disjoint or of preneur
many many use a special case the second
and Weyer is a stretch code is a stretch
okay of stretch of belong to stretch up
stretch out and second one the third one
is is a stretch of is closed and the end
now can try to deal with this using the
ovulation observation we just covered
before so first we have an illustration
of you stretch out of stretch hole now
we first write her stretched out as at
Eastern all of you - dredge hole now
we've navigated now at Eastern or I
factory to satsang and then enter is
just a multiplication to have switch the
order now it becomes Eastern or of
Industry of you got stretch out of
stretch hold and now you actually hope
you've closed under to here and that it
become the strength or of stretch out in
a threshold of stretch whole finally
become destroying the aura of stretch
out of stretch hold and a good thing
here if mr. Anwar can preserve the cap
algorithm and the Pythagorean so now we
arrive at this Namjoo Barack with the
non trivial he'll agree the or category
the for stretch of stretch hose will
imply the similar evidence for industry
of stretch up stretch hold and this will
imply X and next is not being stretched
this was for evaluating and special
special on many inputs reduction from
that to said that increased ankles or
sharps that Ryan's talking about
evaluation progress so it's like like
even a stretch of stretch of circuits we
all know the output of this circuit
every input and here we're talking about
santaguida
which is different
so to go from one to the other you would
need the evaluation algorithm to work on
unbounded and indoors as opposed to
bounded been demands yeah the keep on
how we can make use of this is like it's
an industry so switching these two is
still pretty Gnomeo if it's become like
end of our so polynomial everything will
don't work out guys you kinds of
majority majority cap just save us
so columbia factor and run your time
from the put first algorithm and it will
impact the next it's not being stretch
up stretch hold and this problem seems
simpler than the stretch up stretch up
case because we know that that expensive
lower bound for magical majority so the
real question scares can remind any none
should be set or cat algorithms from the
expansion lower bound poops
the majority majority or stretch our
majority and this you we can do this
that this will imply an axe it's not
eating stretch out stretch hose is
always talking question yeah so
so now this faction actually have
connection to penguin come back with you
so the English style I will I will show
how can we yeah we can actually reduce
the set up with that better question for
stretch up stretch hold to this natural
question seeing conditional geometry and
that the technique device panda you just
through the arrivals into two paths and
you enumerate all assignments to each
other path and you do some reduction so
the first question is Mathematica closes
pure we are you are given points which
are either red or blue being like for
example poly log dimensional Euclidean
space and you want to find the coated
the closest pair the second question is
you want to find the photosphere and the
third question is like given points and
then have appearance in Prolog
dimensional Euclidean space and yes you
use some point on some - use an
algorithm which can shape other logs
from the trivial N squared time
algorithm for these questions then the
that would imply an ax is not eating
structure of stretcho now that will have
to be deterministic
so this passion seems to be has nothing
to do with circus and they said they
seem to be innocent come there's no
judge question which has been studied
for many years so probably you can
review some tools for conventional
geometry to get wasted three steps and
lots of them another passion is a simple
cat look like a question so we are given
two sets a and B for in imaginal
brilliant actors and then integer t the
approximate if you choose that random
pair for a times B whether the poverty
happens there in the product is bigger
than T with some edible arrow epsilon
final reduction from majority majority
cap to its question you can show even a
brief question you can you can get to
analyze this and approximate the
probability with in universe pranaam
poly block arrow into the two over lock
two little one and time and it would
impact an axe it's not instead of
special this seems to be a simple
looking pasture and I have been think
about this whether we can show some
better generation has dementia algorithm
for this and how it lead to the lower
bound well we want
so the kind of them questions can wait
factly improve the complexity of this
problems or show why they are so
actually unlikely and you will succeed
in this
this will show an ax is nothing
structure of stretch hole finally I want
to talk about another interesting
connection which is Alfred I thought
you've cow you've got a newspaper but
it's not about stretch up stretch is
about gentle stretch of circuit so we
know Kate said the best one in time is
to learn times 1 - 2 y over K if the
handing input for many years and also we
know the general general lower bound for
general stretch of circus company adapts
xyron is that 1 + 2 n - 1 path say - - d
say some constant here so this lower
bound will become linear when the depth
is the hologram yeah so actually we
don't know any non-terminal upon against
the local Open Text stretch of circuits
it's even consistent with the current
enough knowledge that e to the MP has a
special circuit of logo and depth and
the wires
so we can't trace or something like you
the algorithm for K that can be slightly
improve it to this so originally is the
one over K but now we keep the Cape
become the dependence on K becomes
slightly better like this would imply
each to the MP has no or inside block
love and death stretch all circuits this
is beta reduction for a whole circuit
set to K set in recent work so now I
want to conclude the talk and the
summarize welcome questions so so first
we show something you couldn't without
for stretch it out stretch out so I show
any initiative casts from the
algorithmic perspective so this two
casts are you cribbing financial help
set algorithm and this class are
equipment for non-trivial cat algorithm
and also we show a non trivial
algorithms for this class and the or
non-trivial category for this cast with
the entire and ax it's not in structure
of structure and we can read after the
tax increase issue and the panel we got
that slightly improving the running time
of of geometry questions will imply next
is nothing in stretch up stretch hole
and we have three open questions
since we still have some time I'm sure
what you've got some another question I
was thinking about but I don't know the
answer
maybe that if if I think also it could
open it up so we know expanded open
against the threshold of maturity and
previous discussion we know we have a
top or gate at the you might we have a
tub or gate then this will mix the
pasture and equivalent okay anything
about can we show a lower panel or food
to stretch enough majority circuit it
seems like it seems like it should be
very close to a stretch of stretch all
right family are a lot of problem but I
don't know how to forget it since I
think maybe already known but I service
far well it seems it seems to me like
probably this circuit already has
already had a life sign rank so we
cannot use the thermic method but anyway
this seems very close to setup stretch a
majority so we should be able to prove
some lower bound I'm used to put a
number lower bound so this is the final
open question I want to ask here yeah
thank you
[Applause]
the results are about left g20 circuits
and any prospects for the three circuits
so actually the equivalent way that well
for the equipment equipment here holds
for all that so I can show but our
constant ax t the question for arbitrary
ways and and the parameter weights are
equivalent
this could be helpful for the further
development of the finding collaborative
yeah
but currently I'm still focusing about
stretch of spatula second spear that
isn't just cause or to threshold Oh
majorities that contagion I think is to
be the threshold of degree two functions
I'm not sure how it acts or to time this
true but I'm not sure or to actually
that lower bound I just hope that and
the tool of stress showed this
dysfunction has an expression as an very
large may be rooted stretch or degree
so and to abstract how it thinks it is
from the perspective of structural
degree it's already / ha ha ha saying
certain threshold usually look a degree
2 polynomial essentially degree of
stress hold out for ending is annoying
because it seems kinda simple right but
I don't know about the question of only
works for nano-sized so I think we Ryan
prove that original upon the for like
and to one point four sides of social
majority but a lot of that you go pencil
I want to ask whether the epic pronoun
no super Fernando upon a positive class
and if team talkin to me so and Roy Roy
tells show something like suppose how
did the p.m. the BFE question so it's
the boolean formula evaluation question
we can show this is nothing special
look it off and to one path to over T
for any state bigger than 1 then this
will imply and say one is not equal to
achieve a European is the depth
oh my god but that just says that good
reason the Whitney heart for pumpkins in
NC 1 yeah beyond NC 1 yeah that's true
that's true yeah
more questions
[Applause]